okay hi to everyone joining this live
stream we are talking about things to do
with the rendering of trees
so
where should we start
right so
go ahead noah
well no i i was just going to say that
we um we had done sort of uh i guess uh
a quick review of this ux um at the end
of the ild meeting um and so this new
thing is about sort of going through
um
this whole proposal properly
okay um
uh yeah it's it's so it's it's
a view for trees which was just tray
outlined in the previous meeting we
discussed that there could be other
layouts as well um but we're starting
with this one um
do we think this is the only tree
outlined we think there will be many
tree outlines
so we also have john in this meeting for
uh tree view
so what is tree view versus tree outline
so
the uh uh i mean this is something that
i just rolled together a quick proposal
for uh the interesting thing that i
wanted to focus on here is the
possibility
that you might want to view something as
a tree that's not a fully
realized uh expression um
so the interesting thing about uh tree
views
is that uh you can compute them lazily
you know they can be closed and you can
uh
it's sorry the uh
did you
well in any case
yeah oh yes that's right
the i think that was it's just something
that
displayed the associates but so like
imagine for example
the tree view on a file browser you
probably haven't you know
thought about it
maybe as much quite in this way because
you use macmore but on windows you know
it uh you often see these tree views
and
you know the the contents of a closed
item
are computed when you open it um
and that way you can have a preview that
represents an entire file system but you
don't have to wait to scan the entire
file system to show the tree view
right
well and the same could be true of our
both i mean
you know for example with graphs
well for instance in in find replace
path and other kinds of
things that we're looking at for this
multi-computation project
it's the same story that is that you
might have you know a game graph you
don't actually compute the structure of
the game graph until you've explored
down to that game configuration
wonderful wonderful i'm glad to hear
that you're thinking of other
applications too so the reason i wrote
this up is because
you know the first four
patterns there are kind of obvious it's
the fifth one that's really interesting
to me
preview of a function
i'm not sure that's the right way to do
it though because i think that it might
it
it might not be but
something that allows this is exactly
right
so
i think
essentially the function that you want
to specify is the function that we have
in nest tree
yes a function that takes the current
state and gives the list of child states
right
although with this aware thing that
we've been just talking about
you could have those child states depend
on further context
right
i mean normally
like in nest graph
you are purely computing the next states
plural from the current state
but
but like the previous the past states
the stack of states is irrelevant
but with aware for example the stack of
states could be included
for example
i mean the the concept for john and
other people's benefit
of this aware function i'm not sure it's
the right name but i kind of like that
name it's situational awareness
is you would say something like map
and then default form
you would say index plus
um
you know stack or something you know
list
something like this
comma expression
and that would do you get what this is
did you get the concept john
no that would do what
well so matt think of map index okay
so
in this case map
of
aware
of let's say the map index was going to
be you know f of
the index position comma the expression
okay
that would be
that would be equivalent to
map indexed
of f of first of hash two comma one
okay
isn't that a cool idea
um okay but but that's a way to
generalize that's a way to not worry
about the fact that normally
in this you know this is a
quintessential multi-way system story
i mean there is a question when you
generate those tree elements of whether
you should merge identical elements that
you generate
right because that's an issue if you're
generating a tree
and like for example a quintessential
case would be
um
okay it will be something like this
right it's a tree except it isn't a tree
because there are two different ways to
reach the four
does that make sense right
well the uh yes i'm very familiar with
this because this comes up in uh
uh
when you're constructing uh director day
cyclic word graphs um
for word games um that uh
which is i mean you know there are
dictionaries here
it's it's the same concept for
spell checking dictionaries is that uh
uh you know you're just following nose
of the graph as you're going through the
letters of the word
but if uh
you know if every terminal node were
unique the thing would be huge
uh so you just you know
share the nodes at the bottom
where they're identical
and and then where it got to the same
word where the different spellings got
to the same word no where it got to the
same terminal and so you know a node
that is like you know ends here
or can take an s and then ends
you know
that that note is shared everywhere
um but you know that would be different
from ends here can take an s and then
ends or can take an s or or it can take
a d and ends you know those are
different nodes so you know something
that only takes an s at the end
is going to end up in a different node
than something that can take an s or a d
oh
that's interesting okay
um and and it's just basically a way of
packing the dictionary because if you
didn't pack the dictionary it would just
you know take a pretty large amount of
memory but
when you pack it
in you know is certainly in the english
language and in many other languages too
it it packs down really very nicely
all right but so so the issue for
treeview is what does it do when these
things get shared
i think we don't want to have sharing
for the treeview well i mean if it's
tree no obviously not but but that's the
case
okay can you do nest tree with the same
arguments get rid of the vertex labels
what others
well i mean this is running in
version
13 1 so i have no idea what that means i
can try it in version 13.
okay something's wrong 13 1.
so the point is i'm like in like a file
system if you had
files with the same name in different
directories you don't want to share
those
um
okay
well unless there's symbolic links and
things
uh
okay
there's a bug you should be aware of but
but um all right so let's come back over
here
i i mean what about what about
expression view you know what about the
illusion of expressions which we've
discussed for like 25 years or more
right so i generate a complicated
expression let's say i have you know
uh
oh for goodness sake not the silliness
again
we have to fix this i hope this is
getting fixed for
okay
all right so so in an expression like
this
you know i should be able to see in a
lighted form of this
and then click to drill down am i making
sense
do you understand what i'm saying
like an interactive short
yes that's what we've discussed for like
25 years
right i mean this is a tree structure
you should be able to elide it down and
then see it
so what you're proposing here
and what i think john has here
is
you know he's got an association version
of this
you know another version of this that we
already have is a data set
that making sense
yep
so what is the you know what's the
commonality between these different
forms
i think i should look at your actual
design here
and and is this design this design is
quite separate
from the tree view design over here
correct
so
um
you know i was just suggesting a syntax
which could
use or which could look like this but
that doesn't mean that it would
necessarily be the the most elemental
thing that looks like this
looks like what looks like this over
here yes yeah yeah exactly so we have an
issue that you know having something
that behaves
like uh uh you know that looks like it
behaves like what you're seeing on the
left is
not so easy to do um
and so we may have to actually create a
new box in the front end to do this um
okay and then i was just imagining kind
of um
you know what you know so there's the
box and then there's the things you
would build on top of the box right
um
and so i was imagining actually i take
that back actually i i think the thing
on the right was what i was imagining
being the most elemental version and
then you could build things on top of it
why is this i don't understand why this
is
oh this is successive
successive
instances of the trio correct yeah
and how does this relate either
functionally or graphically to the data
set opening
oh if you scroll down um i think it's in
the illusion section yeah
um so we
we looked at
essentially combining the elements of
the the ux from data set with this so
it's just keep scrolling
and then if you for example open
uh so we've taken the breadcrumb trail
we've taken the drilling down um we've
taken well you can see what else we've
taken
okay
okay all right so let's zoom out here
for a second
right i mean
to me one of the things that i react to
not so positively
is the kind of seeming preciousness of
the but maybe i'm just
incorrectly reacting
of this kind of structure it's like well
this is one particular graphical way you
could represent it but there are a
million others
and and that you know an example of that
is the pure opener type mechanism here
so
one advantage of a uniform
a more uniform representation
is that you can build a pretty obvious
keyboard accessibility on top of it
and for many things maybe you don't care
about keyboard accessibility but let me
tell you that when it's useful boy it's
really useful
well so what are you saying so you're
saying i could type j to get to the
jupiter cell here uh and and you can you
know go around using arrow keys you know
right to open left to close up and down
to navigate
i bet i've never discovered those for
the you know file browsers that i use
but
um
okay
i'm not saying that's an absolutely
killer feature but it is interesting
yeah but i'm trying to think i mean so
let's say you've got a big xml tree is
this going to be a good representation
of it i mean don't you need to be able
to say i don't understand this
in um so i mean if i were to take
okay first of
all first of all do we even have a
function
that
um
uh
that basically um
goes from a data set to a tree
so
we will add
support for that in expression tree so
you'll do expression tree of a data set
and you'll get something that looks like
that outline there
okay which outline this one here yes
a tree
data like that using like keys as
payloads
okay but why isn't that displayed by
default as a standard green tree type
thing
i i would just say in general displaying
a file system or a large xml document as
a graph is
just not very helpful but an outline
where you can open and close things
right but the question is there's a sort
of smoother way to get to that
by having some you know max tree size
for this kind of tree and i mean there's
no nothing that says you can't have a
tree that is displayed like this
well i don't know i mean where you could
open things by clicking on elements of
the graphically
arranged tree yeah but that's going to
be way less useful right because it'll
have to rearrange the whole tree as
opposed to just the spot where you are
it would either have to rearrange the
whole tree or it would have to come up
with the
arrangement in advance which might look
insane when everything's closed up oh
yeah okay fine
and you know i i think it's uh you know
there are at least two use cases maybe
let's call them out explicitly uh one is
visualization and the other is drill
down
yeah i agree i mean and this thing
allows multi drill down is that true yes
open up multiple pieces yes but if you
drill down everything in a big uh
you know in a big graph it becomes
progressively less useful
uh in the same way that on the visual
visualization side you know if you have
a big thing and you just visualize
everything it becomes progressively less
useful
okay
all right so
just for some reason this this
appearance
just seems
it sounds very precious and and but but
but one of the nice things about this
form of drill down as opposed to the
other form that you
mentioned is that
uh you can undrill
i know so
so that's you know
as i say it gets progressively more
difficult to use the more things you
open up but you can you can close the
things you're no longer interested in or
you realize that we're just a mistake
right what would be a way i think the
opening and closing are separate from
drilling down so you can open and close
everything that's visible independently
and i think that's what you're calling
drilling down
i i was thinking drilling down is like
in data set when you click on
a key like a sub key and it shows you
just the data set
you know that sub data set and here
there's a way to
show just some subtree which is distinct
from the opening and closing behavior
yeah you double click on either a node
or a release to drill down to it
and then you get the breakfast out of
the top
that is
weird what
i think
i think that's weird i mean i i can't
think of a
of a tree-like view
where the equivalent of opening a folder
in a file explorer
rather than just
you know from outside opening a bunch of
right but that's but but that's
yeah but that's not
right that that that's can you scroll
down so we can see
i that's a distinct view in the file
browser right you have the show me just
this folder and when i double click
uh you know
open that folder and then there's you
know show me the file system tree
and you know i can right arrow and left
arrow to open sub folders
but
you know
well so for data set there's a way to do
this that doesn't require you to extract
a subtree and then visualize that
separately you just click on something
right well yeah i i guess i would
uh you know
i would be concerned about the
discoverability and you know how do you
go back
noah has a design for that going back
yeah the going back mechanism isn't too
bad if you scroll down
um
uh keep going keep going keep going
there you go okay so any of those will
do um
the the node that's essentially become
sort of the roof of that view now has a
little back icon so if you click on that
you go back a level um and then you also
got the breadcrumb tray at the top so
you can you know you can immediately go
to whatever level
in this in that
in that path that you want to
draw
in a file explorer
okay we've got three things here we've
got tree exploration we've got data set
exploration and we've got expression
exploration
which in a little a little bit of which
you're doing over here
so
go ahead
can i just ask is there supposed to be a
back icon i can see is it just too small
for me to see on my screen because i
don't see a back icon
there's there's a less than there's a
that's down sign there ah okay
okay it also
has a little piece of branch coming out
of it to the left as well it's going to
show that it's
you know it's a piece
maybe you can bump up the magnification
trying to but for some reason the cell
is refusing to magnify i thought you
could type command period on a command
plus on a cell and have it magnify is
that not the case uh it changes the font
size but if the cell has internal
font sizes set
um
it's not a magnifier it's just a font
size thing so right if you're i i assume
that's some sort of screenshot so if you
right click on it right there should be
a way to or maybe just click on it right
there should be the
there you go
thank you
okay
uh that how yeah that still looks like a
c to me although i guess having been
told that it's a go back that that's
pretty subtle we can deal with we can
deal with this you can only get into
this state by having clicked on the node
to begin with
right but i just want to come back to
this question about an expression
a large expression that would have like
a you know could potentially be shown
with the output limiter or be shown with
short
doesn't it have exactly the same issue
as this
do you understand what i'm saying
right well uh
in principle yes right we don't even try
to solve that problem at the moment
right i know i know i know but we've
been talking about that for years
i guess different expressions will have
different natural representations an
array is more like a data set but a tree
is more like this and something
intermediate will be something different
okay
but even even a data set even the
concept of auto shortening that is that
we have a a you know like in the output
limiter
where a particular piece of the
expression has been you know shortened
but you can't yet click on the aligned
part in the middle
do you understand what i'm saying like
like
if i were to make
here
something where i say short
like that right this incredibly ancient
thing should be clickable somehow
am i making sense
yes but this feels very
different that you'd want a completely
different layout surely to what you've
got on the left well i know but but the
difference is this is a long linear
structure that you want to see more of
this is mostly
a tree drill down structure that you
want to see deeper of so to speak
here you want to see longer of it here
you want to see deeper of it usually
the interface you're providing here is a
device right
insofar as you're providing a longer
interface it's only through the
scrolling mechanism
uh making sense
correct
yeah i mean there are ways of increasing
that sort of scroll bar um the you know
the sort of max item size image size um
but yes yes i agree
um
okay but that's why i was saying that
they they feel like different things
and so
well no i'm trying to unify the concept
i'm trying to understand that we because
for an expression there is also
tree-like drill down in some cases
an expression that is for example the
the tree expression from a tree
will be
a heavily drillable object
whereas a long list along a re you know
uh you know a long list here
is a readily extrudable object
if i'm making sense
you know you want you want to see more
of it that way
as opposed to drill down into it
by
opening subparts so what you're
providing here
is primarily an interface for opening
subparts what except for the scrolling
part
right so what i'm trying to understand
what is the global
you know because you're talking about
tree view which is for expressions
but
in a sense there's also a kind of an
alighted view
in which
for example things like this should
happen
does that make sense
right well i think
one of the issues is you know
how you want to i mean right we're
looking at sort of the two extreme
simple cases of well you have a flat
array of atom a flat list of atoms and
sort of something that are very bushy
trees
um you know in a lot of expressions it's
context and user dependent
which way you want to drill down and how
you want to align i agree like look at
this one i mean you could you could
either have said x arrow well we could
have either done the thing that is
essentially you know this is a good
example of of different kinds of
drilling i mean so here for example i
might have said um just this
and i might have said oh i don't want
that i want to drill down inside here
you see what i'm saying
i mean this is a fine top-level
representation of the result it's good
actually
but it's a question of how the drilling
works and right now the drilling doesn't
work here which i find fairly annoying
it's also it's difficult to work out how
you go back up as well so if you'd open
something
um
it would obviously have to have its own
little x or something in the top right
hand corner
yes yeah um
could you collapse the entire thing as
well with the whole thing be framed
that whole list be framed as well and
you could sort of get all the way back
to the state of like
you could just see the route yeah just
one blob so to speak for the whole thing
yeah right yeah
so well i mean sort of like
yeah
yeah i mean then you still have to
decorate the whole thing frame it
right so what you're saying is that that
could be something like in a lighted
view which you're saying is orthogonal
to what you were talking about today
primarily you're saying that
uh yeah yeah
okay all right so let's concentrate on
but i also think it's it's interesting
and worth um
uh
it it does feel different especially
because of the sort of free
form layout of it as well if that makes
sense
um
yeah all right so let's look at your
trees
here
okay so
um
the name is questionable
tree outline so wait a minute that there
are
what how is this accessed how is this is
this a
currently the idea is you'd say tree
outline of a tree object
as opposed to a rendering
and since 12 3 if you do tree outline of
a tree object it returns a nested opener
view
and this is a
new
[Music]
design for what tree outline should
return
but what if you wanted is it feasible to
want something which is displayed as a
graphical tree down to the leaf 14 or
something or node whatever at which it
is displayed as one of these things
for which
it would make more sense to have it be
an option
for a tree
how it is displaying itself
are you saying the thing about having
like openers in the graph view
yeah that's what i'm saying
is that crazy
well that's what we said i think it's
harder
and not necessarily what we want
right away for xml and
other things
right yeah i think he's making a
different suggestion that
you know the bottom level rather than
just cutting up off at the bottom level
the bottom level becomes
one of these three outlines
yes
right so i'm saying
that it's a different thing if you say
tree outline or tree view and i don't
know the difference between those and
that's very confusing
um
of a whole tree that is bank switching
the whole tree to be you know shown in
this in this way
which seems different and i'm asking is
it something where you want to be able
to incrementally show this
did you get what i'm saying
to have
both aspects of a graph
and
this kind of outlined view in
yes that's what i'm saying but which is
but but let's look okay let's look at
what you're doing here well so
it might work if it if instead of it
sort of having to rearrange the tree
uh it sort of popped
popped out um and you sort of got the
open view i see on top attached on top
yeah yeah that's the only way i can
think about working without it being
really frustrating
no i agree
yeah right it's got to pop on top rather
than it's a pop over not a exact exactly
the thing that rearranges so what's the
relationship between tree outline and
tree view
right so tree view is a control
right so it's
you know you you give it some
information and then the the front end
can take over
um
tree outline actually converts a tree
into some
other representation which by the way
uses a tree view probably
correct
and why is it the tree view given a tree
doesn't just become the viewer
well you're saying it does down here yes
right but uh yes uh it could def
definitely do that but it wouldn't
um
[Music]
right it wouldn't sort of do
um why wouldn't it do exactly the same
thing i mean we can't have both the
function called tree outline and a
function called tree view
that's not a possibility so i don't
understand why tree view isn't basically
i mean this is essentially a control
isn't it
yeah so i mean i'm i'm not uh
necessarily going to claim that treeview
is is is the name that we must be wed to
but
i do think that there should be a thing
which maps to
what we do in the front end
okay
and and and and the the tree view as i
documented it was my initial proposal
for
a thing that does that okay i wouldn't
have been able to figure out from the
name tree outline that what it does is
this
i mean a tree browse seems a little bit
closer
or tree browser
i mean the the inner file viewers isn't
that
the uh file outline it's not what you
sort of get
is that what it's called
i didn't know that this was that's cool
i don't think i've ever encountered a
term file outline
i would i would expect it to be an
outline of an individual file right
don't they don't you just say tree and
in certain context you expect it to look
like
this
yes but what would propose in the in a
terminal it's just gonna output
something that looks like this it's it's
it's
kind of
us who's saying that tree
uh visualizes as a tree graph as opposed
to an outline
okay but i don't call this an outline
it's not and that's like what so what
did how does the name tree view
communicate that it renders as no it
doesn't it's not a good name it's not a
good name because treeview suggests that
it is in fact other than the hint from
the word view it suggests that it looks
like a tree which is this graphical
thing that we're showing above
right and and also with tree brows there
i think there's other
notions of browsing like you might want
to have instead of things nested have
them side by side
as you're drilling down well i agree
although that might be an option
i don't think it's a very good look tree
outline is not a good name and tree view
is not a good name for the this thing
what is this thing
i mean i don't know the u.s literature
may have a name for it but what is it
in now
and the reason i use treeview is because
that's what microsoft calls
you know the the actual widget itself a
preview
okay
the
but i don't think i mean the question is
what is the natural name for this object
uh
okay but anyway we don't know its name
but it is some function tree something
or other and perhaps that function has a
as a mirror
in the front end although i don't
understand why the functionality needs
to be different so if this was called
tree browse that would be called tree
browse view or something in the front
end i don't really understand why these
have to be different
uh
but then we're asking what is the
functionality over here
of i mean this functionality looks
pretty nice
i mean i don't know what happens if
these things are graphics that are
bigger for example
am i making sense right say say if you
tried to do an outline of the csg region
tree
for example yes
where
and i don't know how the
um
for example if if i was going to do this
from a raw expression
i guess i have the exact same issues as
expression tree
of how do i go from the expression to a
tree
yeah we just want to
provide as
many built-ins
for converting expressions into trees
right and then what you're saying is
that this
given that you converted the expression
to a tree if you just say
show me the tree it will come out in
graphical form you know like green
you know i don't know what we want to
call it but that's what it currently
does i know that's what it is
and so they're not expressing an opinion
on whether it should do that by default
or not
right but it would be nice
if whatever was returned
by
xml import
was something i mean this is clearly a
much more useful way to return the data
structure is still a tree
so that's that's why this wrapper
it's unclear to me whether it should be
a wrapper or an option because for
example the xml import could return a
just a a communal garden tree like you
know a tree that grows in a communal
garden so to speak haha um but with an
option that causes it to be displayed
in this
uh
what is this display this is a kind of
line listing it's a line
it's a textual tree display in some
sense
it's a
well it's almost a vertical tree display
it's a
chapter and section
you know it's an open closed tree
display right another criticism of the
name tree outline is that
you know notebooks form an outline
but they
are completely different than this
well right but this is
you know one question would be if i
read in a notebook object
and then i
pre-viewify it what will i see
and that will be a good example of
something like the xml tree
of
kind of um
you know what
you got what i'm saying well well i mean
it depends on you know what sort of tree
you're interested in you know what what
are the what are the atoms of the tree i
guess you know is it i mean you could uh
view it as a symbolic expression uh you
could view it as you know where the uh
you know cells and you know it's just
cell groups you could view it uh you
know there are others you know what what
are the leaves of the tree it kind of
defines what what what you mean by
viewing a notebook as a tree right and
and and
sorry to interrupt you but but yes that
that is the point i was trying to make
earlier that you know preview just or
whatever we call it just sort you know
it sits there and facilitates front end
kernel communication and displays the
thing now if we wanted to go in and
analyze and
somehow customize based on the content i
think that would be the tree outline
function
well i don't think either of these names
is very evocative but
in i mean the point that i'm making is
think about the import
you want to return quotes a tree
but one that by default displays in this
linear form or whatever we call it
am i making sense
right so that's an argument for there
being an option to tree
that determines its display structure
just like
you know
you know we've got
well look here's the thing we've got a
graph layout option which dramatically
affects the way the graph is laid out am
i making sense
yes but i i think i disagree with that
because with graphs there are still
points connected by lines well here for
example imagine a tree in which the
payloads are numbers you may want
a visualization based on rectangles of
areas proportional to those numbers and
this is tremendously different and it
will require its own options so i think
it's better to have a function dedicated
to the options of that
visualization
enough but but but then what would you
return
look look here's the problem you you
take in an xml tree from import
okay then you want to do operations on
it you don't want to be unwrapping it
you've got
the following issue
and by the way i don't think that these
are incompatible i think we could have
an option as well as
a rapper
just like we have for many other kinds
of things
um but i would say that the idea would
be
that the import could have set the
options so that were you to see the
default display of the xml tree it will
be this linear form
making sense
but nevertheless
if you were to do operations on it you
could operate on it like a tree you
wouldn't have to say first to extract it
from its display wrapper
see what i'm saying
so what i'm arguing for like dataset
yes i guess so
well
i guess
except dataset actually appears in the
language well i guess i guess this would
appear in the language but there would
appear as an option as opposed to
well i'm saying that just like oh i see
just like dataset could have its display
options set by the importer
i don't know whether that actually
happens right now but it certainly could
happen but yet the thing you get out as
the delivered object is a data set that
is capable of being manipulated in all
the ways the data set can be manipulated
right
okay
so
what i'm arguing is that's a reason
okay so i would say the obvious thing to
do
is
there is a wrapper function
possibly that wrapper function should
actually return a tree
like for example graph with a new graph
layout will i think return a single
graph with a changed graph layout just
like show returns a single graphics
with changed options and so on correct
well if this is just an option to tree
then it will work like that you can do
tree of a tree and specify new options
fine but then what i'm arguing is there
should be a rapper
that
essentially who's whose action is to set
those options but that means that we can
return from things like import
i think we don't need that we don't need
a rapper that sets the options that
wrapper is just tree
well yes we do i think so i guess the
other alternative would be it's just an
inner
thing
that the front end takes care of how it
forms yes i know but what i'm saying is
i'm saying i think the flow should be
this there should be an option to tree
that specifies its layout
okay
then there should be some wrapper
functions which are convenient just
because you say hey i want this tree
in this linear form and that may be a
convenient thing to do
you know rather than i mean maybe maybe
it's sufficient to just say expression
tree blah blah blah comma
pre-layout arrow linear for example
you see what i'm saying
that may be a sufficient way to do it
not making sense
yeah i mean i would argue that the the
reason the only reason it would be
useful to have a dedicated function is
if there are classes of sort of
preset options based on content that
you'd want to say so i know like you
know calculate
you know open enough sub
sub trees so that i immediately see a
hundred nodes or something i don't know
yes
but those could be we've got to have a
way of of
having
rich options that are part of the tree
layout specification
whether you give those in a wrapper and
they then seep into the innards
is a different question i think
right well right
well my point the point i'm making is
sure you can manually
if we had these options right you
certainly it should be the case that you
can
manually set on a hundred nodes
you know this one should be open in the
initial state um
but if you just have the tree and you
want to
want some function to calculate which
nodes should be open for you based on
some criteria
that's where you have value for a
function
so tree
just for context tree outline currently
just everything is closed by default and
the second argument is a position spec
and it opens all of the ancestors of
those positions so that you can see them
and then there's yeah the third separate
thing that etai's mentioning of
specifying which
nodes are initially open and which ones
are initially closed well that's kind of
like short short tries to sensibly close
up things that you know where you still
see the structure but there's big things
are alighted
you can imagine the same thing for tree
does that make sense
yep
um
okay and
i assume so another thing is
underneath the node
being able to easily
say how many things are under that node
right just like we do in the very useful
thing that we do in documentation where
each subsection records and arguably
that's the thing that we should make be
a front end option for general closed
cells john
is
what again sorry i missed that putting
the number of elements that are below
that closed cell in parentheses after
this cell content we have something
uh
similar to that which is uh in
which was you might remember this was on
by default in 2.2
was uh
uh there was kind of a length meter
uh
yes yeah
i think that was too analog
yeah i mean i mean it didn't you know
it didn't give you any basis for it was
only like relative measurements were
useful it didn't give any any absolute
notion right i think that the idea that
i certainly find useful in documentation
of saying how many things are there
underneath this closed
you know
cell is something we could generalize
but it's something also relevant for
trees here
yeah
okay but so let's let's loop back again
okay so i think what with what we're
saying is there needs to be a syntax for
a pure option to tree some kind of tree
layout and we have a somewhat rich graph
layout although i'm not very we have a
tree layout option
what does it do you can specify
different graph layouts or you can
specify top bottom left or right for
the orientation of the tree
all right
well then we either need a version of
that that does this linear layout
we need a yet separate option which is
sort of the master layout concept
because the actual existing tree layout
option is going to be pretty vestigial
in cases where you're specifying the
linear layout right
they seem different like the tree layout
option
is like options for
the the tree graph format i understand
that i understand that we could easily
make it be the case that
for some setting of tree layout it is
specifying this linear layout or some
other kind of layout
and then has its own separate options
for the linear layout just like for the
you know graph layout there are and it's
not very elegant and it probably needs
to be reviewed sub options
to like
uh you know
i don't know
uh layer diagraph embedding you know
root vertex and yes
right i mean i i think there's a rather
inelegance and probably we do better
sort of packing them all into an
association when it needs to get rich
like that
and arguably
we could do a thing
where you know where it says tree layout
arrow linear
and then
somehow that is in a list with an
association or something i don't know
exactly how it should work which can
give the voluminous options there
but then the convenient
kind of i just want by the way i mean
you know right now we have a layered
graph plot function which i don't use
but instead
although i should have used it for
something i was just trying to do
yesterday now that i think about it it
would have been a good idea maybe that's
the way to um uh to achieve something
anyway um
the uh
um
i would actually like something called
layered graph
which basically
all it does is it sets
you know because i do that all the time
i have to reset
between you know spring electrical
embedding and layered diagraph embedding
and so on those two
and it will be quite convenient to have
a wrapper
that simply sets those without having to
grunge inside you know graph of g comma
you know graph layout arrow whatever i'm
making sense so what i'm suggesting here
is a wrapper that similarly
you know succeeds in
um
uh
you know switching this to being a
different layout of tree and has a
convenient way to give the options for
that switching
in that outer wrapper function
making sense but the end result would be
a tree with certain options
set which therefore would also work in
import etc and be able to be manipulated
just as a tree
are making sense
yep
so now in terms of what this looks like
unfortunately i do have to go fairly
soon here but but um
uh
i mean i'm sort of warming to this
although i i'm
and i mean i'm kind of
what do people think of the term linear
view or linear
i mean it's really it's a series of
lines it's kind of like a
like a
presentation basically
right i mean it's kind of like a it's
almost like a textual view
except that we can't guarantee it's got
text
and
i just
i fear that linear view sounds too
it's wrong
yeah yeah i would never have guessed
what linear view okay well fine but what
is this what is this view because
the
somebody is somebody in the live stream
uh suggested hierarchy view
yeah but the problem with that is that
everything's a hierarchy yeah
nested view
all right
is suggesting opener
view branch view i don't know
we already have open review just that it
doesn't work on trees it doesn't digest
trees
maybe it should
well tree outline returns opener views
correct
tree outline
wait a minute this is tree outline
is this an opening
this is a new design
where potentially it doesn't return
opener views anymore
so wait a minute so
what you're seeing there with just the
triangles mercury venus that's what you
get currently so if i say random tree of
100 for example
oh for goodness sake well
the compiler is currently broken and
13-1 built so
that's reassuring
for me
okay so there's my random tree and now i
say what do i say here tree outline
oh i see
well that's pretty useless
what is the head of that expression
openly tree outline oh open a view
oh my gosh
so we can't manipulate this
yeah
that's a design mistake
what
i mean i mean that
surely
surely the opener view should have been
uh a typesetting step not an evaluation
step
right i mean this is not set in stone
these are experimental things as well
this is so this is kind of like tree
rules like this was kind of understood
as like a conversion function
oh sorry i i sorry i thought three
outline was the thing that already
existed okay well i don't know i'm
saying initially yes so when we added
tree outline in 12 3 i was thinking of
it as a converter from tree into opener
view which maybe is not a like you said
maybe that should have been just an
inert thing that formats using open
reviews
okay but so so we have a bit of a muddle
here on our hands
so
i didn't realize that tree outline was
already an existing thing although it's
still an experimental thing
i have never used it
uh
and clearly your design the new design
is vastly better than the existing thing
what is the relationship between the new
and and you can you can see by the way
one of the really critical flaws uh
in in tree outline in the uh ref page
there is that
uh it is not easy to tell
that that a and b
are not peers
there should have been a level of
indentation that is not there
i agree and noah added that in the new
design
yeah
okay but totally baffled by that point
the first time i saw a tree outline okay
so hold on
opener view
why doesn't open a view support this new
format here
well i mean the front end doesn't know
anything about trees or compile or data
structures or whatnot no i understand
that but i'm saying that conceptually
this seems like it's perfectly
applicable to open a view
um
so part of the payload of opener view is
a dynamic variable that tracks the open
state
a single dynamic variable that tracks
the open state well that's not good
either
look we have a bit of a muddle here yeah
right opener view is right it's a two
element thing right it's
yeah it's just like a control it's a
standard control like slider and so on
right but my point is it doesn't
represent the whole hierarchy right this
is a bunch of nested open reviews not a
single opener view
and columns too
fair enough
but i mean look this was a quick
implementation of this which is
interesting
but
i don't know wrong
you don't need to mince words i i think
nobody don't think anybody will be
offended if you just say it's wrong
right okay so so okay i have to leave in
a moment here but but um
what we're
doing
okay so where are we going from this
we got to think through that that all
these different things about tree layout
versus
you know what goes inside the tree
structure
what is a
an inert wrapper
etc i mean i favor things going inside
the tree tree structure and just
displaying that way
you know displaying according to the
option that was given there
um
i also
want to understand i mean clearly you
know
for
35 years 34 years we've had the whole
mechanism all our lovely mechanisms
for outlining in notebooks
right
and my question would be what can we
learn
from the ux which has worked really well
of notebook outlining
for tree outlining
to someone i'm saying
because a notebook outline is a tree
outline it's just a tree outline where
the payload elements are typically
rather large
and where the number of hierarchical
levels
is typically defined by styles and is
comparatively small
right whereas a tree outline of the kind
we're talking about could go much deeper
it's levels
i mean one could imagine something where
we would actually want to style every
level just like we do in notebooks you
know
title section subsection sub subsection
one could imagine wanting to do similar
styling on a tree over here
i would think tree element label and
tree element style like those options
for trees should
work
right but i mean one could imagine
trying to specifically stay
you know relevant for this kind of view
the level one
format is this the level two format is
that and so
on um
well okay i think we need to wrap up
here
but
you know we clearly need to talk more
about this
maybe you guys could have a think about
well the the things we've been saying
about putting this as an option to tree
and so on
and some of these other things about
unification with notebook outlining
unification with data set outlining
which you have thought about a little
bit unification with short and so on
sorry i mean this is more complicated
than than
we perhaps thought
i think in terms of the you know the
pure ux look is looking
for some reason it looks a bit overly
precious to me but
but just in terms of design
but the functionality is nice
what sorry what what do you mean by
pressures nobody but stephen knows oh
i'm sorry sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
maybe that's some criticism
i've been trying to work it out while
you've been talking
it's a britishism but the british kid
asked you
well
okay
so we must call it precious my precious
yeah
yeah yeah right no oh gosh that and that
that probably is from okay
drat um
no what i mean is it's got
it's sort of
overly detailed it's kind of like the
you know in the skeuomorphic design
department of you know put
uh
you know
of having
things that look pseudo-representational
or something that's a bad description
but it's kind of like too much detail so
to speak
somehow
that's why you were pointing out the
sellout the the cell brackets maybe
because that's
less yes it's sort of achieving the same
thing that is that's a good that's a
good
way to say fragile you know kind of like
like there's a lot of stuff here there
are certainly versions of this that have
uh
less ink i guess might be a way to put
it
um yes yes i mean clearly this has less
ink but it's also incomprehensible right
but i think you know our cell brackets
are rather beautiful in that respect
right right and no there are there are
good versions of this with less ink so
yes we we can figure that out
right yeah okay that i'm sorry i gosh i
have to you know one thing is learning
new words
and the other is realizing that words
you use have completely gone out of
circulation
um
and uh
uh
yes
um
i think i've heard that term in in
graphic design rather than in american
graphic design it's always very hard to
remember when one learned a word
i'm pretty sure i've heard that word in
context from american graphic design so
it made sense to me but it's one of
those words maybe it's just an inside
circle that people understand what
you're saying
okay fair enough i mean is that
okay maybe a designer would i don't know
maybe
maybe american designer works nowhere
in a different loop of um
um
okay
um
but i'm glad we clarified that uh
okay well we should wrap for now and um
to be continued good thank you good
stuff okay bye for now